the Joe Rogan experience when I first
got here the hot book was you'll never
work in this town again
hmm it was a hooker who [ __ ] did a
tell-all book about Don Henley calling
her up to a house and they had a bend
over and Don Henley would snort Coco
after her [ __ ] whoo and then get up
plug him once and sit back down and just
sit there so you had to go to Don
Henley's house he has a fireplace for
women he would just say bend over naked
god damn don't snort coke get up [ __ ]
you for a minute and sit back down it's
not Marco you know she told all those
stories at different movies I'd be [ __ ]
like that would she be disappointed if
you lived any other way I would think
that if you're living back then to rock
star back then like you almost were
required to do something ridiculous like
everybody was doing ridiculous [ __ ] like
no there was no like clean and sober
rock stars back then we're there like
that hadn't even happened yet where
people cleaned up right people clean up
regularly now it's a big part of society
like people improve how many people
cleaned up back in the day right like
artists artists that were like really
into drugs they just died yeah no Kurt
obviously a suicide or whatever
depending on which documentary was 1983
you know put 12 [ __ ] 12 feet pipe in
your truck wiring screws and there was
just one [ __ ] drive aground that was
45 years old and his wife was 15 whoa
and he would bring out a work with Jesus
she'd be in the front seat she did not
go to school
the owner know everybody knew he if you
looked at him you could tell he wasn't
all there yes and I'm a masculine once I
just dissed your daughter it was I asked
my wife I go she's 15 14 he was yeah the
parents sold it to me oh Jesus Christ
I forget what his name was away he led
no he will live the Western yaki was a
white dude from West Nile but he that
you know but Don Johnson married Melanie
jumped Matt Melanie Griffith's before
she was 18 really yeah look it up she
was nobody said dick was that uh look at
the other boy look at you that dude
they're gonna throw him on the chair
when they finished with who are Kelly if
you think how he wine stands in trouble
at least how he got some Marvy ha ha ha
we Harvey at least he's got some money
left
Arkel he's done and like we were [ __ ]
nobody said nothing our Kelly used bribe
to marry Aaliyah
when she was 15 charges say he bribed
government employee in 1994 so that he
could obtain a fake ID for the singer
Aaliyah mmm yeah this is 20 something
years ago right he did this he's gonna
they're gonna throw him under the [ __ ]
in jail he was holding a woman captive
[ __ ] with the head you're not allowed
to talk to your [ __ ] parents you know
was it all that age is it all like in
the 15s that's what he's into is that
what yeah yeah they've got the video of
him pissing on a chick which I never saw
I don't want to see it I mean I had no
[ __ ] desire to see that [ __ ] what do
you think that is you think he's
basically like like running well I was a
little bit of his last week and he comes
across to you he is professional
Elizabeth listen some people know whom
to deal when they see one and that's
what these woman is saying that his
professional his skill is the art of the
wounded woman and then he plays wounded
but then you know who do you talk to him
that within the first day I'll tell you
they got sexually harassed not too many
people so as soon as he starts at that
you start with your story about your
uncle and he's gonna take care yeah he's
gonna do this and this that's how he
went in oh the stories that these woman
is saying I just
[ __ ] crazy like it's just other level
[ __ ] craziness my manipulation you
know it's just deep old-school pimping
me you and I want to see American pimp
yeah I went to that barbecue place you
took me to a good barbecue place next
door there were American that was that
used brothers just that mentality I was
spotting those type of woman's you know
it's [ __ ] up but it's horrible and I
feel terrible about it and it just makes
me feel sick hearing the story but what
makes me laugh is if we found out that
JLo had been capturing 15 year old boys
and pissing in the face we would think
it was hilarious
if JLo went to high school and she got
all these sophomores and she brought
them back to her place for a gangbang we
would think these kids had a good
[ __ ] time that is well it's it's one
of those big giant differences between
the way we feel about men and women this
our Kelly thing is horrible but it is it
is kind of funny that if our Kelly was
like a really beautiful woman and she
she was doing the exact same thing to 15
year old boys making them live with her
and eat her [ __ ] inch it would take two
larious we would just think it's
hilarious as vile as doing it yeah
Madonna's doing it he does not read or
write exceedingly well except when it
comes to amazing musical tracks his turn
he said okay he doesn't read or write
well and that's sad the whole thing sat
if it is weird our ideas of sex based on
gender
it's [ __ ] very different very we feel
very different about that story there'll
be a hilarious story if there was some
big tittied freak singer who has their
little sex call and she brings 15 16
year old boys over we wouldn't really we
would be like wow but we wouldn't feel
like a crime got committed we're
hypocrites because yes I make jokes of
it on Twitter I see it another 16 year
old teacher sucks a dick you know but
then you think Jesus Christ I have a
daughter this swings both ways
[Applause]